good morning John it's Monday that's the
sentence that I haven't said in years as
weird but for people who haven't been
following the vlogbrothers for more than
a year you might not know that it's
about to get weirder here at
vlogbrothers channel because the project
for awesome happens around December 17th
it's gonna start tomorrow at noon
Eastern Time and you might not know what
that means so that's what this video is
about since 2007 on December 17th we
that is you and me and John and
everybody's watching
nerdfighteria all of the internet
community that wants to be involved
participates in the project for awesome
my hair is terrible right now what is
happening the idea is to just spend one
day of our Internet experience instead
of on super wholock and cat gifs spend
it on making the world a better place we
do that in a few different ways one
people make videos promoting their
favorite charities and then upload them
on noon Eastern Time or there abouts on
December 17 to people submit those
videos to project for awesome comm where
they can be voted upon by the entire
community 3 there's an IndieGoGo
campaign this is how we raise the actual
money there are lots of perks that you
can get here there's a man of YouTube
charity calendar there's a women of
YouTube charity calendar we did both
this year so let's see who wins usually
everybody wins
obviously a bunch of nerdfighters
created their own artwork which they
sent to us for free even paying for
postage so that we can have it be part
of the nerdfighter art perk you can get
a haiku with your name in it made by
george watsky unless your name has more
than seven syllables in which case
that's just not gonna work also in
addition to that you'll get his new CD
time I have too many shirts so I'm gonna
make all of my shirts except for like
the six that I love the most and have
sentimental attachments to I'm gonna
have these also are available so you can
get a shirt these of all I think
appeared in vlogbrothers videos they're
just my shirts I now have six shirts
you'd also get this one there are men's
mediums if you're wondering the
IndieGoGo campaign is there to raise
money last year we raised four hundred
thousand dollars this year we have
matching donations up to one hundred and
twenty-five thousand dollars from an
anonymous donor thank you anonymous
donor for we're still gonna list if you
forgot there's a livestream that starts
also at noon Eastern Time on December
17th a livestream is basically everybody
hanging out and slowly degenerating into
madness and commenting on videos but
mostly to generate
the madness you don't want to miss it
well watch a bunch of videos together
you'll comment on them and if you like
them you'll go and vote for them at
products are awesome calm and finally
number 5 after I go and had a chance to
vote the charities featured in the top
voted videos will get a cut of the money
donated to the IndieGoGo campaign
everything that we don't spend on
processing costs or shipping or printing
stuff like that goes to the fund to be
split between these charities there's so
many other perks that I haven't even
talked about there's a chance to win a
book signed by JK Rowling alright of the
first two chapters of john green's new
thing that he's working on which i don't
know if it's gonna become his new novel
but maybe i have a christmas album that
i even mentioned that i did a Christmas
album throw the project for awesome it's
only it's digital only and it's six
songs maybe seven i haven't quite
decided a lot of it's recorded not all
anyway there's much to do the next few
days are gonna be crazy the live stream
is hosted here on vlogbrothers channel
so you can join us for that please do it
to commenting fingers ready and john
i'll see you tomorrow